Sera's in washington my parents are in
their late 50s with no retirement or
savings and they have debt if they got
serious about paying it off they could
be debt-free in one year my mom works
part-time as an in-home caregiver she
makes very low wages but says this is
her Christian ministry that is very
noble but I feel she's putting their
future at risk by not taking their
situation seriously how do I talk to
them about this well it's difficult to
get someone to fix a problem if they
don't think there's a problem and so one
of the things you can do when you're
trying to discuss with anyone is just
try to explain the problem what does
retirement look like if you keep on this
track where are you going to be you
could get them a copy of Chris Hogan's
book retire inspired as an example and
start the conversation
what does retirement look like at the
track you're on if you keep doing what
you're doing where are you gonna land
and most of the time people are fairly
aware of the fact they're gonna be broke
because they're heading towards broke
now add to this the equation though this
chemistry that it is your mom who didn't
ask your opinion likely doesn't want
your opinion as a matter of fact you
might be the last person on the planet
that she would take their opinion
parents have a lot of trouble taking the
opinion of their groom children we call
this the powdered butt syndrome once
someone has powdered your butt they
don't really care what you think about
money or sex most of the time sometimes
there's an unusual father or parent to
child adult relationship where you can
actually speak into it but most of the
time there's a whole lot of background
music when you're trying to have a
discussion they're all the past and all
the memories and all the things so your
email sounds pretty judgmental I don't
think you're wrong but if you use that
tone with her
you're probably going to get nowhere so
a couple things you can do one is you
could just ask questions about where you
where they think they're going to end up
how's it working for you it's kind of a
dr. Phil moment how's that working for
you the second thing you can do is talk
about not them but you mom you know I
used to be really scared about
retirement ie dad I used to be freaking
out about our debt and now we've gotten
on a plan we paid off this debt or you
know it looks like we're gonna we're
trending towards being millionaires when
we retire we're heading in that
direction and I can actually show you
the math it's pretty fun we're having a
good time over here I used to be doing
some dumb stuff now I'm doing some smart
stuff and you just tell you no one can
really argue with your story so you tell
your story the power of your personal
testimony tell your story that's about
as good as it gets and the most you can
hope for is that he or she will say wow
I wish we could do that you know I think
you're good or what you show me how to
do that absolutely I'll show you how to
do that and then you can get into the
discussion and I would probably not even
address what she does making low wages
as her Christian ministry I would let
her come to her own conclusion on that
you know you might be looking at the
thing and go you know if y'all made a
little more money you could do this from
a little more money you could knock this
debt out as soon as you got that knocked
out you'd be able to do this and you
could retire with dignity but you were
going to change your income what would
you do to change your income and just
ask questions don't go mother you need
to get a better job that is not a
Christian ministry you're just washing
out you don't need to say that you're
thinking it you might actually be right
but don't bring that up let her come to
the conclusion a lot of you guys come in
sit down with your wife and go work get
out of debt we're gonna sell your car
that just doesn't work people but if you
get her on board on what it'll be like
to get out of debt she may come to the
conclusion hey I need to sell away sell
my car and now that'll work but you got
us situations up where people realize
they've got to do things and if you're
treating the symptom rather than the
problem you're never gonna get there so
tell you it's a pretty low probability
for adult children to have successful
conversations with
parents it's very unusual it takes a lot
of little seed planting a lot of little
moving and but you definitely can not be
a bulldozer through the front of the
house it does not work you might get by
with that with your best friend but
you're not gonna get by with that with
your mother